[Musique]
la secrétaire d'état cristal du boss et
série melchior président du département
et des en visite protocolaire au rsma de
la caserne lambert le régiment du
service militaire adapté de la réunion
est un acteur important de la formation
et de l'insertion des jeunes
il s'appuie sur une structure et des
statuts militaire pour dispenser des
formations professionnelles de 6 à 12
mois
c'est ce que nous rappelle cyrille
melchior président du département
c'est important de voir ce que propose
le rsa ma à nos jeunes réunionnais vous
savez que l'insertion la lutte contre
l'exclusion pour nos jeunes est un
domaine extrêmement important
moi je salue la qualité du travail qui
est effectué ici parce que eux près de
1400 jeunes réunionnais passe par le
rsma le département soucieux de
l'accompagnement de ces jeunes est aussi
présent à travers la mobilité
professionnelle département est au plus
près des réunionnais des jeunes
réunionnais doit favoriser leur
radiation
grâce à ces 38 formations le rsa 1 serge
chaque année près de 76% de ses jeunes
volontaires
[Musique]